# U si löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi fürnes neus Dahei.
.
# U si stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi fürnes neus Dahei.
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
# Eifach uf u dervo.
Vor einem Jahr haben wir
Schweizer Auswanderer begleitet.
Familie Hensler
zog es nach Schwedisch-Lappland,
wo sie eine Hotel-
und Campinganlage übernahm.
Oh mein Gott!
Was für eine Unordnung!
Can we start?
Weitab der Heimat
eine neue Existenz aufzubauen,
verlangte dem Ehepaar viel ab.
Im ersten Jahr ihrer Auswanderung
schlitterten Yasmine und Max
in eine heftige Beziehungskrise.
Ja, wir haben uns getrennt.
Es ging nicht mehr.
Auf ein neues Abenteuer
liess sich Familie Blum ein:
Mit Kamelen trekkte sie
durch das australische Outback.
Ho-ho! Stand, hey!
Die Kamele
waren zwar störrischer als erwartet -
doch richtig ernsthafte Probleme
bereiteten ihnen
die Besitzer der Tiere.
Wir sind abhängig von ihnen,
das ist so.
Sie können uns
die Kamele verweigern.
Das wäre eine Katastrophe.
Und da waren Cornelia Breitschmid
und Jean-Marie Suter.
Sie verliessen Kölliken im Aargau,
um in Marokko
eine Feriensiedlung aufzubauen.
Ab hier stehen dann die Gästehäuser,
mit Swimmingpool ...
Ein grosser Traum.
Doch noch mächtiger
war die marokkanische Bürokratie.
Im Moment
habe ich einen solchen Kopf
und bin ein bisschen frustriert.
Ihr Vorhaben scheiterte.
Wir haben
das Projekt Tabouka gestoppt.
Kurzerhand mieteten sie
eine riesige Villa auf dem Land.
Wie geht es den Auswanderern heute?
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
Der Sommer ist
im hohen Norden Schwedens angekommen.
Nur wenige Kilometer
vom Polarkreis entfernt
herrscht eine Hitze von über 30 °C.
Alle fangen!
Es ist nicht selbstverständlich,
dass Familie Hensler
so entspannt zusammensitzt.
Die weitläufige Norrsken Lodge
zum Laufen zu bringen,
war eine Herkulesaufgabe.
Die weitaus grössere Herausforderung
für das Paar war jedoch,
wieder zueinanderzufinden.
So einen müssen wir auch haben.
Jetzt darf Kimi.
Es ist ganz anders als letztes Jahr.
Viele Abläufe stimmen,
wir haben gutes Personal.
Wir haben uns organisiert.
Wir wissen, was auf uns zukommt
aufgrund der Erfahrung
des letzten Jahres.
Ich bin entspannter, weil Yasmine
mehr im Geschäft integriert ist.
Viele ihrer Vorstellungen
scheiterten an der Realität.
Etwas jedoch blieb:
Ideen gehen Max
noch immer nicht aus.
Die neueste Attraktion:
ein Drachenbootrennen.
Auf dem Fluss fanden früher
internationale Rennen statt.
Das war ein Riesenhype.
Nicht mit diesen Booten,
sondern mit Kajaks.
Das ist ein Drachenboot, ja.
Ich habe sie von der Schweiz her
ganz anders in Erinnerung.
Mit richtigen Drachenköpfen.
Der muss noch befestigt werden.
Der Schwanz ist schon dran.
Doch bevor die Boote
in den Tornea-Fluss stechen,
schauen wir mit der Familie
auf das bewegte erste Jahr
ihrer Auswanderung zurück.
Gut, danke. Willst du selber fahren?
Hallo?
Wer ist hier drin?
Die Reise in ihr neues Leben begann
in Einsiedeln vor knapp zwei Jahren.
Willst du den mitnehmen?
- Aber klar doch.
Er ist ein bisschen kaputt.
- Das macht nichts.
Die Leine ist abgefallen,
aber das macht nichts.
Ich war noch nie dort.
Ich war schon im Norden,
aber noch nie in diesem Ort.
Das ist für mich
eine grosse Überraschung.
Aber ich vertraue Max voll und ganz.
Yasmine hatte die Anlage
im Internet entdeckt.
Als ihr Mann Max
den Kauf per Handschlag besiegelte,
war sie jedoch
mit den Kindern in der Schweiz.
(Alle) En guete mitenand!
Nicht mogeln!
Wir müssen als Familie
davon leben können.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Sonst sind wir bald wieder da.
Auch für die Kinder muss es stimmen:
mit Weite, Natur
und Ursprünglichkeit.
Die Auswanderung
ist für die Familie eine Chance.
Max wird in Schweden
komplett neu beginnen:
Der Projektleiter wird Gastronom.
Erst vor Kurzem hat sich Max
von einem schweren Burn-out erholt.
So, okay.
Für mich ist es ein Lebensabschnitt,
der zu Ende geht.
In den letzten zehn Jahren
ging es mit meiner Firma BrainMax
auf und ab.
Ich gründete damals
eine eigene Firma
für Beratungen von Supply Chain
und Interim Management usw.
Ich erlebte
international sehr vieles,
bis ich vor eineinhalb Jahren
ein heftiges Burn-out hatte.
Kimi hatte eine schwierige Geburt.
Wir mussten zu dir schauen.
Es war schwierig.
Es war in dem Sinne schwierig,
weil er nicht sich selber war.
Er hatte keine Nerven, er war ...
... sehr angespannt.
Es brauchte nicht viel,
und er explodierte.
Unausstehlich.
- Ja, wortwörtlich.
Du kannst messen.
Keine Löcher in die Kisten machen!
Unterstützt von der Familie
und mithilfe einer Therapie
fand Max langsam
zu seiner alten Kraft zurück.
Er war bereit, sein Leben
wieder in die Hand zu nehmen
und ihm
eine völlig neue Richtung zu geben.
Das hat mich
ein bisschen aufgewühlt.
Alle Therapeuten und Ärzte
rieten mir davon ab:
"Ein Burn-out und dann auswandern,
das bedeutet noch mehr Stress."
Für mich war das
die Chance auf ein Comeback.
Ich war so enttäuscht,
dass ich ein Burn-out hatte,
es nicht geschafft hatte.
Für mich war es eine Möglichkeit,
mir zu beweisen,
dass ich es schaffen kann.
Max ist als Erster
nach Schweden losgefahren.
Im Gepäck den Hensler-Haushalt
und Familienkatze Aisha.
3'000 km Wegstrecke
liegen hinter ihm.
Mädchen,
bald haben wir es geschafft.
So cool!
Aisha, wir haben es geschafft.
* Jubelschrei *
* Lachen *
Scheisse! Aisha!
Kaum angekommen wird Aisha
zur ersten grossen Herausforderung.
Aisha!
Komm runter, Mädchen!
Nein, nicht nach oben!
Komm runter, Aisha!
Komm runter! Komm runter!
* Miauen *
Ich sage nichts zu diesem Thema.
Ich war nicht dabei.
Du hast mir nichts gesagt.
- Ich habe es Yasmine verschwiegen.
24 Std. ohne Schlaf und Hunderte
Kilometer Autofahrt in den Knochen -
seine Aisha jedoch
holt Max selber vom Baum.
Aisha, Aisha!
A little bit right.
To the right ... Yes.
Aisha, alles gut.
* Klagendes Miauen *
Alles gut, alles gut. Ich bin's.
Alles gut.
Yes!
Welcome to Övertornea!
Es ging
wie ein Lauffeuer durchs Dorf.
5 Std. da, und schon bekannt
wie ein bunter Hund.
Einen Tag später kommt Yasmine
mit den Buben Janne und Kimi an.
Hallo, Schatz.
Wir haben's geschafft.
Freche Lausbuben.
Hey!
Yeah!
- Du trägst keine Socken, oder?
Hey, Kimi.
- Ich will runter.
Das gehört alles dir, Janne.
All das!
Du kannst überall spielen.
Schneehaufen!
Juhu! Gehen wir rein!
Für Yasmine
ist es ein grosser Moment:
Zum ersten Mal
sieht sie ihr neues Zuhause.
Nein. Dann würde ich es
eher so hinstellen. - Ja.
Dann hat's wahrscheinlich Platz.
Da könnte man
einen Kleiderschrank hinstellen.
Z.T. ist es noch schmutzig.
- Ja, ja.
Da oben ist noch braune Sauce.
Da müssen wir halt ... Nicht?
Die Lampe hier geht nicht.
Ich kann dir sagen,
was die zuletzt gegessen haben.
Ich weiss nicht mehr,
was mir durch den Kopf ging.
Aber für mich war es ...
Aber da ich die Fotos gesehen habe,
viele Fotos angeschaut habe,
war mir das nicht fremd.
Das neue Zuhause der Henslers
ist mehrere Fussballfelder gross.
Dazu gehören ein Hotel, zwölf
Ferienhäuschen - die sog. Stugas -,
40 Stellplätze für Wohnmobile
und als Herzstück der Anlage
der Gemeinschaftsraum
für die Campinggäste.
Gehen wir rein, komm!
Das ist das alte Gerichtsgebäude.
Das hat so dicke Holzwände.
Das ist heimelig.
Cool. Es ist wirklich toll.
Es war ein schönes Gefühl.
Und v.a. ist es riesig.
Ich stand da und dachte:
"Ist das gross!"
Dieses Gefühl habe ich nicht mehr.
Wir könnten
eigentlich noch ausbauen.
Scheisse.
- Meine Güte.
Komm, wir gehen in die Garage!
- Achtung!
Oh, schau mal!
* Kimi kreischt vergnügt. *
Wow.
Schau mal!
- Ein Kompressor.
Dieses Chaos.
Im Grunde genommen
müssten wir eine Mulde haben
und dann einfach mal ...
* Sie macht Wischgeräusche. *
Sie müssen das entsorgen, Maus.
- Aha.
Es wird noch eine Weile dauern,
bis sie das alles entsorgt haben.
Ach, du meine Güte!
Das war eine Katastrophe, nicht?
- Echt katastrophal.
Es kostete auch viel Energie.
- Ja.
Wir freuten uns darauf,
unsere Ideen umzusetzen,
doch überall lag Abfall.
Ich putzte
drei Wochen lang die Wohnung
und schmiss 40 t Abfall weg.
Can we start?
Max ist keiner, der sich schont.
Nebst den Aufräumarbeiten
beginnt er gleich zu renovieren.
Die Decke des Restaurants braucht
dringend einen neuen Anstrich.
Sein Koch Jeppe und Helfer
aus dem Dorf unterstützen ihn dabei.
Im Business hat man immer 100 Tage
Zeit für die erste grosse Änderung.
Wer in den ersten 100 Tagen
nichts bewegt, sollte es lassen.
Mit dieser Managerweisheit
setzt er sich gehörig unter Druck.
Jeppe.
- Yes?
Feuerlöscher.
Nächsten Dienstag kommt einer
von der Versicherungsgesellschaft.
Wir brauchen überall Feuerlöscher.
Haben wir einen beim Eingang?
Ja, aber das ist auch der einzige,
den wir haben.
Denn auch
scheinbare Nebensächlichkeiten
muss er als Besitzer der Anlage
im Griff haben.
Es fehlte an jeder Ecke:
kein Feuerlöscher,
keine Bewilligungen,
keine guten Abläufe,
kein gutes Personal.
Überall entdeckten wir Schäden,
die wir schnell reparieren mussten,
wir haben realisiert,
was wir renovieren müssen.
Und dann noch auf Schwedisch ...
Ja, das war eine Herausforderung.
Noch leben die Henslers
eine traditionelle Rollenteilung:
Während der Vater
das Geschäft vorantreibt,
kümmert sich
die Mutter um die Kinder.
Es wird sich schon noch ändern.
Wenn Janne in die Schule geht
und Kimi ab und zu im Hort ist,
dann kann ich
die Buchhaltung übernehmen,
dann kann ich das da oben machen.
Zum Mittsommerfest,
dann wenn in ganz Schweden
Maibäume aufgerichtet werden,
feiern die Henslers
das Eröffnungsfest
ihrer Hotel- und Campinganlage:
der Norrsken Lodge.
Die beiden Bürgermeister
von Övertornea
geben dem Fest eine offizielle Note.
Soundcheck.
- Soundcheck!
So, it's my turn.
Vi hade en vision för atta ar sedan.
När vi besökte Skandinavien.
En vision att skapa en plats
för människor att träffas ...
Ich war so stolz auf dich.
Das war
eine ganz schreckliche Übersetzung.
Tack sa mycket.
C'est bon?
Im Alter von 60 Jahren
hat Jean-Marie Suter
dem Leben
nochmals ein Abenteuer entlockt.
Der Frührentner
und seine Frau Cornelia Breitschmid
leben seit über einem Jahr
in Marokko.
Er braucht immer wieder
ein wenig Starthilfe.
Die Batterie ist vollkommen leer.
Und in der neuen Heimat
kaufte sich Jean-Marie auch
ein Stück Jugenderinnerung zurück.
Ja, ein Traum ...
Wenn es schon einen R4 hatte,
dann wollte ich wieder einen.
* Der Motor stottert. *
Ich glaube, wir müssen es aufgeben.
Ich merke gerade: Ein Esel
funktioniert besser als ein R4.
Doch so schnell geben sie nicht auf.
Ein bisschen Gas geben.
* Der Motor springt an. *
Schön.
* Orientalische Musik *
Wie der R4 hatte auch ihre
Auswanderung einen holprigen Start.
Mit dem ambitionierten Vorhaben,
eine eigene Feriensiedlung zu bauen,
scheiterten sie.
Aber die beiden Abenteurer
fanden schnell einen Ausweg.
Auch mit ihnen
wollen wir zurückschauen.
An einem regnerischen Herbsttag
nehmen die Marokko-Auswanderer in
Kölliken Abschied von ihren Liebsten.
Auch Jean-Maries erste Frau Brigitte,
die Mutter seiner Kinder, ist da.
Und natürlich auch die Kinder
samt Anhang und Enkeln.
Nebst sechs eigenen Kindern
adoptierten Jean-Marie
und seine damalige Frau
noch Zwillinge aus Indien.
Hallo, wie geht's?
- Gut. Und dir?
Liebe Gäste, liebe Freunde.
Die einen denken,
wir seien vielleicht verrückt.
Das sind wir, ihr habt recht.
Wir hoffen,
euch in Marokko zu treffen.
Samuel, Jean-Maries ältester Sohn,
tut sich schwer
mit den Plänen des Vaters.
Für meine Kinder
hätte ich mir gewünscht,
dass sie
mehr von ihrem Grossvater haben.
Aber wir werden mit absoluter
Sicherheit nach Tabouka reisen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Sämi.
- Tschüss, Vater. Mach's gut!
Kommt schon gut.
Wir kommen bald runter.
Ist gut?
Okay.
Tschüss.
* Sanfte, melancholische Musik *
Das habt ihr gut eingefangen,
tipptopp.
Wir wussten, dass wir jetzt gehen.
Wir sitzen in den Flieger
und hauen ab.
Da kamen natürlich Emotionen hoch.
Ich bin kein Heimwehtyp.
Deshalb gelang es mir relativ gut,
loszulassen.
Ich brauchte eine Zeit lang,
um mich hier heimisch zu fühlen.
Ab und zu erwachte ich und dachte:
"Was machst du überhaupt hier?
Spinnst du?"
"Du hast
die ganze Familie in der Schweiz,
bist aber selber in Marokko."
Marokko,
die neue Heimat der Aargauer.
Im Hinterland
der Küstenstadt Essaouira
haben sie sich
in ein Grundstück verliebt.
Hier soll ihre Feriensiedlung Tabouka
entstehen.
Achtung, Schildkröte!
- Nimmst du sie mit?
Die nehmen wir mit.
- Nein, die nehmen wir nicht mit.
Doch, pack sie in den Kofferraum!
- Wir finden noch genug.
Unterdessen haben wir genug, nicht?
Du musst wieder
auf die andere Seite.
Gib sie mir!
- Nein.
Sie gehorcht mir nicht.
Zur Besichtigung des Geländes
ist auch die Architektin gekommen.
Sie hat bereits die ersten Pläne
für die Siedlung entworfen.
Und die Baubewilligung zu besorgen,
ist auch ihre Aufgabe.
So, jetzt sind wir da.
Das ist
eine steinige Angelegenheit -
zu unserem Glück, denn wir werden
mit den Steinen bauen ...
Genau.
Geplant ist, dass an dieser Mauer
unser Häuschen steht,
in dem wir dann wohnen.
Hinten ist alles Werkstatt,
Landwirtschaft, Tiere.
Ja, die Planung war vorhanden.
Und auch die Zuversicht.
Wenn ich mich jetzt so reden höre,
muss ich sagen,
dass ich damals sehr überzeugt
von unserem Projekt war.
Noch hat das Ganze einen Haken.
Noch gehört ihnen
das Grundstück nicht.
Ohne Baubewilligung können sie
das Land gar nicht erwerben.
Und die Bewilligung, die steckt
irgendwo in einer Amtsstube fest.
Noch nimmt es die ehemalige Leiterin
des Aargauer Sozialdienstes gelassen.
Diese administrativen Abläufe
treffen einen überall wieder.
Jetzt bin ich halt
auf der anderen Seite.
... planifier les travaux. Et puis
commencer le plus vite possible.
Schon damals spürte ich ...
Im Büro der Architektin.
Kurz nachdem die Auswanderer
das Landstück entdeckt hatten,
unterschrieben sie eine Absichts-
erklärung für dessen Kauf.
Alles schien auf gutem Weg zu sein.
Doch das ist nun eine Weile her.
Es ist schon vier Monate her,
dass wir den Vorkaufsvertrag
unterschrieben haben.
Ich möchte
jetzt den Kauf abschliessen.
Wo stehen wir denn eigentlich?
Es ist ja schon eine Weile her, dass
Sie das Baugesuch eingereicht haben.
Ja, aber die Baukommission hat
seit vier Monaten nicht mehr getagt.
Die haben einfach getrödelt.
Die Architektin hat eine Idee.
Die Schweizer sollen sich
direkt mit dem Chef der Provinz,
dem Gouverneur von Essaouira,
treffen.
Das sei ein offener Mensch -
er tanze sogar auf Facebook.
Okay.
Madame, wann denken Sie,
dass wir eine Audienz
beim Gouverneur bekommen könnten.
Ich werde Druck machen.
Wenn Gott will - schon sehr bald.
Das war eine mühsame Episode.
Damals schon -
und auch jetzt noch ein wenig.
Bei uns sitzen sie im kleinsten Dorf
regelmässig zusammen.
Und hier
geht es um eine ganze Provinz.
Vier Monate nicht getagt.
Ich hätte am liebsten
in den Bildschirm gegriffen:
"Mach vorwärts!
Erzähl uns keinen Unsinn!"
Beim Gouverneur hiess es, Wali
in Marrakesch mache nicht vorwärts.
Dann fuhren wir zu ihm.
Später sassen wir
im Vorzimmer von Monsieur le Wali.
Dort sagten sie:
"Sie können nichts tun,
wenn der Gouverneur
nicht vorwärtsmacht."
Man wurde hin und her geschoben.
Und irgendwann merkt man,
dass man auf Granit beisst.
Dafür waren mir
meine Zähne zu schade.
Nicht ausgewandert zwar,
aber aufgemacht
in ein einzigartiges Abenteuer
hatte sich
die Familie Blum aus Davos.
Da hüpfen wir beide gleichzeitig.
Mit Kamelen reiste sie
durch das australische Outback.
Dabei wurden die Eltern Sabrina und
Markus mit Problemen konfrontiert,
mit denen sie
nie und nimmer gerechnet hätten.
Auch mit ihnen
wollen wir zurückschauen.
Im Herbst 2016 ist die Familie
am anderen Ende der Welt unterwegs.
Ihr Abenteuer beginnt in Hawker,
einem kleinen Ort
im Bundesstaat South Australia.
Man stellt sich vor,
wie es sein könnte.
Aber man weiss es ja trotzdem nicht.
Wir sind einfach alle gespannt,
nicht wahr?
Hallo?
Sind wir gespannt, wie es aussieht?
Warum meinst du?
- Weil wir bald da sind.
Auf dem Kamelhof der Familie Ellis
wollen sie wilde Kamele ausbilden
und mit diesen auf eine
dreimonatige Trekkingtour gehen.
Darf ich auch schauen?
- Hello?
Ist es ein Dingo?
- Nein, nein.
Doch wo sind die Besitzer des Hofes?
Warten wir kurz.
Ich glaube, es stimmt schon.
Es gibt hier Kamelsättel.
- Ja, ja.
Hello?
Schau!
Es gibt auch überall Kamelscheisse.
Nachdem wir angekommen waren,
hatte ich kein gutes Gefühl.
Das hat man, wenn man die Sendung
geschaut hat, wohl weniger bemerkt.
Ich versuchte,
positiv an die Sache heranzugehen.
Aber ich hatte von Anfang an
ein schlechtes Gefühl.
Können wir weiterschauen?
Nice to meet you.
Naira.
Should I show you your caravan?
- Sure.
Luke, der Sohn der Hofbesitzer,
zeigt ihnen den Wohnwagen.
Dieser wird in den nächsten Monaten
Blums Zuhause sein.
Ah, das ist das eine Bett für uns.
Wir können es auch so machen:
ein Kind mit einem Erwachsenen.
Und wenn ich mit Papa schmusen will?
- Dann kommst du rüber.
Es wird ein Hin und Her sein.
Abenteuer hin oder her:
Zur Schule geht's trotzdem.
In den nächsten sechs Monaten
besuchen die Blum-Mädchen
die Hawker Area School.
Ich hoffe,
dass es den Kindern so leichtfällt,
wie wir es uns vorgestellt haben.
Ich bin natürlich auch nervös.
Ich bin bei allem die,
die am meisten nervös ist.
Wir müssen immer schauen,
ob im Gras Schlangen sind.
Die sonnen sich da morgens.
Okay, Naira?
Immer gut schauen, wo du hintrittst.
Sabrina weiss, was es heisst,
an einem fremden Ort
zur Schule zu gehen.
Als Kind hatte sie
fünf Jahre in Australien gelebt.
Amira und Naira
werden kaum Schwierigkeiten haben,
die Lehrerin oder ihre Mitschüler
zu verstehen.
Colette.
- Colette, Colette, Colette!
Schon früh hat ihnen die Mama
Märchen auf Englisch vorgelesen.
Während die Mädchen
die Schulbank drücken,
nähern sich Sabrina und Markus
den wilden Tieren an.
Ein Wunder, was die fressen.
Ja, schau mal!
Vor wenigen Tagen noch
lebten diese Tiere frei
in der australischen Steppe.
Der Kamelhof der Familie Ellis
bietet den Abenteuerlustigen
die Möglichkeit,
Kamele zu zähmen
und diese als Zugtiere zu trainieren.
We have time.
As long as nobody gets hurt.
* Dröhnende Didgeridooklänge *
Jetzt werden sie eingefangen
und erst mal an ein Halfter gewöhnt.
Ich nehme an, es wird gleich
ziemlich wild zugehen.
Hutt! Hutt! Hutt! Hutt!
* Das Kamel brüllt. *
Ob die wohl irgendwann mal
zahm werden? Nein, nein.
Leg das Seil um den Pfosten
und zieh das Kamel zu dir hin!
Push her forward a bit!
Out of the way! Shi-shah! Hutt!
Nach der Ausstrahlung dieser Serie
wurden wir
in vielen Medien kritisiert.
In Mails, auf Facebook,
auf "20 Minuten" usw.
Das passierte ziemlich oft.
Ja, es ist nicht so schlimm.
Es ist nicht so schlimm. Hey!
Es trifft einen schon,
wenn man so was hört und liest.
Das tut schon ...
Also mich hat es getroffen.
Mir hat das verinnerlicht
oder gezeigt,
dass wir uns heutzutage
und in unserem normalen Umfeld
nur noch den Kontakt
mit zahmen Tieren gewohnt sind.
Jeder kennt Pferde.
Man kann auf ein Pferd zugehen,
es streicheln,
anfassen und aufsteigen.
Es ist nicht mehr gefährlich,
es ist zahm.
Es wird aber vergessen,
dass diese Tiere mal wild waren.
Kaum ist die Schule aus, kommen auch
Amira und Naira zu den Kamelen.
Die Mädchen
nähern sich vorerst übers Futter
den noch ungebändigten Tieren an.
Nach drei Monaten
intensiven Trainings ...
... stehen Sabrina und Markus
vor einem entscheidenden Schritt:
Unterstützt von Kamelhofbesitzer Paul
wollen sie zum ersten Mal
die Tiere vor den Wagen spannen.
Now, we'll walk around.
Diese Gerade entlang,
da sollten sie laufen.
Die bereits ausgebildete Milly
soll die Zugtiere anführen
und die Richtung vorgeben.
V.a. geradeaus.
Come on, girls!
* Drollige Klänge *
Walk up! Come on! Walk up, girls!
Was macht sie?
Oh Gott!
Come on, Luna!
David gegen Goliath.
Here we go!
- Au! Fuck!
Sabber auf dem Kopf.
Ich hatte eine gewaltige Beule.
- Die sah man noch eine Weile.
Sicher, beim ersten Mal
war es nicht einfach.
Aber irgendwann
muss man mal beginnen,
muss man die Kamele
vor den Wagen spannen.
Wie Kinder probieren sie alles aus,
sind störrischer als ein Esel.
Ich probiere ja auch.
- Ja, du auch.
V.a. Essen.
Das stimmt.
Wir hatten schon
so viel investiert ...
Wir hätten nur aufgegeben,
wenn wir damit unsere Kinder
gefährdet hätten.
Gegen Sonne, Wind und Regen
hat Sabrina
Vorhänge für den Planwagen genäht.
Dieser wird für drei Monate
Schutz, Haus und Fortbewegungsmittel
der Familie sein.
300 l Wasser und Lebensmittel
wie Teigwaren, Gemüse, Kartoffeln,
Mehl und Zucker
haben die Blums geladen.
Passt!
Auch die Kamele
haben Vertrauen gefasst
und sind startklar
für die grosse Reise.
Eigentlich wäre alles perfekt,
wenn nur das schwierige Verhältnis
mit den Besitzern der Tiere
nicht wäre.
Die freundschaftliche Beziehung
hat sich merklich abgekühlt.
Nur: Was die Gründe dafür sind,
darüber rätselt selbst Sabrina.
Ja, wir haben etwas Pech mit ...
den Leuten, bei denen wir wohnen.
Nicht, dass sie böse sind,
aber sie haben ein völlig
anderes Weltbild als wir.
Wir sind abhängig von ihnen,
das ist einfach so.
Wir haben Angst,
dass sie uns die Kamele nicht geben.
Jetzt ist es so nahe,
und doch braucht es nur eine Person,
die Nein sagt.
Das wäre eine Katastrophe.
Wenn ich das sehe,
werde ich sofort wieder nervös,
dann habe ich
kein gutes Gefühl im Bauch.
Ach! Es war eine so emotionale Zeit
mit diesen Leuten dort.
Es wühlt mich immer wieder auf.
Eigentlich ist das alles weit weg.
Aber wenn ich das wieder sehe ...
Das war nicht immer lustig.
Können wir jetzt weiterschauen?
Ja.
Sind sie da,
hast du mit ihnen geredet?
Ich wurde schon wieder angeschnauzt.
- Weswegen?
Ich weiss es nicht,
sie kam wie eine Furie. - Wer?
Sie, Karen.
- Weswegen?
Sie hätte in der Stadt gehört,
dass ich erzähle,
dass wir hier nicht willkommen seien
und 5'000 Fr. Miete zahlen müssten.
Keine Ahnung.
Sie wollen uns nicht gehen lassen?
Ja. Echt der Horror!
Momentan möchte ich einfach
am liebsten weg, weg von diesem Ort,
es macht mich wirklich krank.
Ich halte es fast nicht mehr aus.
Es war schlimm.
So etwas habe ich noch nie erlebt.
Wir haben sicher auch Fehler
gemacht, wir alle machen Fehler.
Aber es sollte wohl
einfach nicht sein.
Du redest es schön.
Wir haben keine Fehler gemacht.
Doch, sicher. - Wir machen
auch Fehler, aber dort nicht.
Doch, sicher auch.
Ich glaube, sie sahen sich mit
einer intakten Familie konfrontiert,
die mit ihren Kindern
etwas Tolles erlebt und unternimmt.
Am Schluss deutete alles darauf hin,
dass es Neid gewesen sein muss.
Das haben uns andere auch bestätigt.
Irgendwann
kamen wir auch zu dieser Einsicht.
Ob wir uns so einfach besser fühlen,
das weiss ich nicht.
Aber es deutet alles darauf hin.
Die haben neues Gestrüpp hingetan.
- Damit niemand reingeht.
Dieses Stück Land steht für Cornelias
und Jean-Maries grossen Traum:
Tabouka, ihre eigene Feriensiedlung
mit Gästehäusern,
Restaurant und Pool.
Doch dieser Traum ist geplatzt.
Die marokkanischen Behörden ver-
trösteten die Aargauer Mal für Mal.
So lange,
bis die beiden genug hatten.
"Liebe Empfängerinnen und Empfänger
unseres dritten Newsletters."
"Im Leben gibt es Zeichen,
welche beanspruchen,
gut interpretiert
und gedeutet zu werden."
Ich schreibe diesen Brief,
weil wir unser Projekt Tabouka
gestoppt haben.
Wir sind ausgestiegen,
sagten: "Halt, stopp, fertig."
Jetzt, Wehmut? Null.
Denn mittlerweile
wissen wir noch mehr.
Andere warteten sieben Jahre
auf eine Bewilligung.
Und dann haben sie einfach gemacht,
oder?
Dazu bin ich nicht bereit.
Ich würde heute
auch wieder gleich schnell stoppen.
Nein, ich würde so was
gar nicht mehr machen.
Jetzt nicht mehr, das ist klar.
Aber bevor man das sagen kann,
muss man
diese Erfahrung gemacht haben.
Doch die Marokko-Auswanderer
sind nach Essaouira gekommen,
um zu bleiben.
Eine Villa auf dem Land
wollen sie nun mieten.
Der Besitzer der Villa, Aziz
Ajarroud, zeigt ihnen das Grundstück.
Und hier ist der Swimmingpool.
(Jean-Marie) Oh-oh!
In dieser Villa
können die Auswanderer
bis zu zwölf Gäste beherbergen.
Das ist eigentlich
ein Familienzimmer.
Das können wir gut für eine Familie
mit Kindern einrichten.
Wir werden mit B&B anfangen,
mit Bed and Breakfast.
Dem Besitzer, der weiter oben
ein Riad hat, werden wir aushelfen.
Etwa so.
Wir werden schön sachte beginnen.
Den Mietvertrag
unterzeichnen die Aargauer
in ihrer neuen Wohngemeinde
Ida Ougourd.
Merci.
Zur Vertragsunterzeichnung
gibt es eine Tajine.
Das war sicher ein Wohltatsschritt:
der Empfang,
die Vertragsunterzeichnung -
das war natürlich wichtig.
Aber der Gockel war unglaublich zäh.
So einen hatte ich nie mehr.
Fehlt nur noch
der Schlüssel zur Villa.
Bei einer Tasse Tee
sollen sie diesen erhalten -
meinen zumindest die Schweizer.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Verstehst du was?
- Nein.
Tres bien. Ah, bien.
Das ist jetzt
die sog. Schlüsselübergabe.
Das muss
ein riesiger Schlüssel sein, was?
Wir werden das nie ganz begreifen.
Das werden wir ohne Zweifel
nie ganz begreifen.
Nein, das ist klar.
Das ist eine ganz andere Mentalität.
Mit solchen Dingen
kann ich gut umgehen.
Zwei Tage nach der Teezeremonie
bekamen die Aargauer
doch noch die Schlüssel.
Und kaum eingezogen,
steht ein erster Besuch an:
Jean-Maries Tochter
und Enkelsohn Amon.
Jetzt bereite ich
die Zimmer schön vor, damit ...
... damit die Gäste alles haben,
was sie brauchen.
Wasser
gehört selbstverständlich auch dazu.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Wie geht's?
- Danke, mir gut. Und euch?
So, gehen wir rein?
Ja.
Du kannst mir die Hand geben.
Jetzt sind wir richtig in Marokko.
Wow!
Mit zwei riesigen Betten.
Amon, hast du hier Platz?
Nein.
Was, nein?
Zeig mal!
Es ist super schön.
Schon bei Nacht ist es wunderschön.
Für mich war das Feedback
der Jungen auf Besuch schon wichtig.
"Wo sind sie jetzt? Was machen sie?"
Auch mit ein wenig Stolz
konnten wir ihnen zeigen ...
... was wir geschafft haben.
Es lebt
zwischen der Schweiz und Marokko.
In Australien
konnten Sabrina und Markus
die Differenzen mit den Kamelhof-
besitzern aus der Welt schaffen.
Seit gut sechs Wochen
sind sie nun unterwegs.
Hey, hutt!
Life is good.
Ja, ich meinte eigentlich dort!
Pull, pull, pull!
Das bringt auch nichts.
* Sabrina und Markus
feuern die Kamele an. *
Good boy, Teddy!
Come on, Miss Molly!
Das Umfahren der Viehgitter
ist für die Kamele Ted und Miss Molly
schon fast Routine geworden.
Other side! Come on, pull!
Back on the road.
Hutt, hutt! Other side.
Wir sind nicht in der Schweiz.
Okay, steady walk!
Die Juninächte
im australischen Outback sind kalt.
Das Thermometer
kann bis auf -10 °C sinken.
Wer zuerst aufsteht, entfacht Feuer.
* Reissverschluss *
Jetzt muss ich ein Foto machen,
wie du aus dem Zelt kommst.
Das ist schon das.
Die ganze Vorbereitung,
die wir hatten,
dauerte wohl viel länger
als jetzt der Trip.
Das ist schon genial.
- Hast du Socken an?
Can I do it?
- And then you can do this.
Okay.
Naira und Amira geniessen
ein unbezahlbares Privileg.
Die totale Freiheit,
rumzutoben, so laut sie wollen.
Weit und breit keine Nachbarn,
die sich gestört fühlen könnten.
Doch die wilde Natur
hat ihre eigenen Gesetze.
Als die Familie mit dem Wagen
über eine kleine Krete rollte,
stürzte Kameldame Luna
und brach sich den Fuss.
Es blieb - Hunderte Kilometer
vom nächsten Tierarzt entfernt -
nur der Gnadenschuss.
Es war eines dieser Kamele,
die wir aus der Wildnis hatten
und von Beginn an
selbst abgerichtet haben.
Dass man sie plötzlich
selbst erschiessen muss,
das ist nicht ...
kein schönes Ereignis.
* Dramatische Didgeridooklänge *
Da waren die Augen drin.
Ja.
Naira schaut das sehr pragmatisch
an - sie ist auch noch kleiner.
Sie war schon auch traurig,
aber für sie bedeutete es:
Jetzt ist sie im Himmel
und es geht ihr gut.
Amira redet nicht darüber,
aber es beschäftigt sie schon.
Ich habe dann mal
einen Brief an Luna gefunden.
Sie verarbeitet das eher nach innen.
Hast du auch einen geschrieben?
- Ja.
Darin stand in etwa:
"Luna, ich vermisse dich sehr.
Schön, dass du dagewesen bist."
Ah, okay.
Und das habe ich auf jeden Fall
ganz sicher geschrieben.
Also, Papi hat mir dabei geholfen.
- Aha. Okay.
Darf ich Miss Molly führen?
Miss Molly?
- Ja.
Okay. Holen wir Miss Molly.
Wer schon als Kind ein so grosses und
mächtiges Tier an der Leine führt,
tankt wohl für das ganze Leben
eine gute Portion Selbstvertrauen.
Willst du sie halten?
Durch das Einfache
die Grösse des Lebens erfahren -
das ist es, was die Blums
ihren Kindern mitgeben wollen.
Erst später im Leben
wird sich zeigen,
wie sie davon profitieren,
welche Werte sie mitnehmen konnten.
Jedes Kind, das so viel Zeit mit den
Eltern verbringt, profitiert davon.
Es ist weit mehr als nur eine Reise.
Deshalb geht es nicht nur
um die schönen Momente -
alles gehört dazu.
Wir haben es bisher immer gepackt,
weil wir einander vertrauen.
Man ist auch im Alltag gestärkt,
denn man weiss:
Es kann kommen, was will,
gemeinsam schaffen wir es.
Ja, genau.
Leise hat sich der Schnee
über Nordschweden gelegt.
Der sensible Familienhund Brian
leidet -
nicht wegen des Schnees,
sondern wegen seines Clans.
Hallo.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Vor 14 Jahren
wurden Yasmine und Max ein Paar.
In den letzten Monaten
haben sie sich immer mehr entfremdet.
Das sind bezahlte Rechnungen
und das Quittungen. Okay?
Nun ist das passiert, was sich nie-
mand gewünscht oder je gedacht hätte.
Ja, wir sind getrennt.
Es ging nicht mehr.
Es war eine schwierige Situation.
Die ganze Saison,
den ganzen Sommer über,
fühlte ich mich
verlassen und allein.
Ich hatte den Eindruck, dass
alles auf meinen Schultern lastet.
Ja, es war eine andere Person
im Spiel, aber ...
... das hat sich erledigt.
Es war nur der Anlass,
der mir zeigte,
dass ich etwas verändern musste.
Ein Wachrütteln.
Diese Person spielt keine Rolle.
Wir haben beschlossen,
hier weiterzumachen.
Wir sind jetzt hier in Schweden.
Wir haben alles, was wir haben,
in dieses Projekt gesteckt.
Es wird momentan
auch keine Scheidung geben.
Das wäre auch
seitens der Bank nicht möglich.
Es wird so bleiben,
wie es zurzeit ist.
Ja.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Es ist völlig surreal,
wenn ich die Schneebilder sehe
und die traurige Musik höre.
Das ist so sch...
- Aber es war damals so.
Ja.
Es war damals so.
Ja, aber ich möchte das
nicht mehr hören und sehen.
Wenn das nicht passiert wäre,
wären wir vielleicht nicht da,
wo wir jetzt sind.
Es brauchte in unserer Beziehung
wohl einen Test, eine Phase,
die uns daran erinnerte:
Es gibt nur unsere Familie.
Das ist alles,
was wir haben und haben wollten.
In der Schweiz hätten wir
uns wohl getrennt. - Möglich.
Denn in der Schweiz
ist für uns alles einfacher.
Wir konnten hier im Gegensatz
zur Schweiz nicht davonlaufen.
Wir mussten hierblieben.
- Ja.
Wir mussten uns
unseren Dämonen stellen. - Genau.
* Gebetsruf eines Muezzins *
Guten Morgen miteinander.
- (Alle) Guten Morgen.
Du hast ein 3-Min.-Ei bestellt,
das aber 5 Min. kochte.
Den Eierkiller kennst du,
sonst erkläre ich ihn dir noch.
Und die Stierenaugen für Ernst.
Ist das gut so?
- Jawohl. Danke.
Schau mal, wie sie dich anlächeln!
Hier ist noch
das "Appenzeller Tagblatt".
Guten Appetit!
- (Alle) Danke.
Vor neun Monaten
haben die Marokko-Auswanderer
den Betrieb
ihrer Gästevilla Tabouka aufgenommen.
Und er läuft wie geschmiert.
Anfangs mussten wir
uns ein wenig einspielen,
den Motor einfahren,
aber mittlerweile ...
... mittlerweile ...
... wissen wir beide, wer was macht.
Bis jetzt läuft es gut.
Es ist ein ganz anderes Leben, ja.
Das Büro
vermisse ich überhaupt nicht.
Den ganzen Tag
in irgendwelchen Sitzungen ...
... oder am Computer sitzen.
Morgens, wenn man zur Arbeit geht,
ist es dunkel,
wenn man abends nach Hause kommt,
ist es dunkel.
Nach der Arbeit
fehlt die Energie für anderes.
Hier haben wir schon
eine andere Lebensqualität.
Zumindest im Moment bereue ich
diesen Wechsel überhaupt nicht.
Voila, heute Abend gibt es Joghurt.
Über Nacht
kommen sie in den Kühlschrank.
Habt ihr für heute
noch einen Ausflug geplant?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Möchtet ihr nach Essaouira,
in die Stadt? - Ja.
Dann rufe ich Aziz an,
ob wir heute ein Fahrzeug erhalten.
Aziz, salam aleikum, labas.
Ecoute, j'ai une question.
Est-ce que tu as
une voiture de l'occasion?
Jean-Marie ist das Oberhaupt
einer grossen Familie.
Sich um Menschen zu kümmern,
ist tief in seiner Seele angelegt.
Tres bien, tres bien.
Früher war ich das Taxi Papa.
Ich hatte sogar eine Tafel im Auto:
"Taxi Papa".
Jetzt habe ich
natürlich erwachsene Gäste,
aber ich organisiere
gerne etwas für sie.
Ich habe ein Auto für euch gefunden.
- Super.
Ich würde mich
für alles verantwortlich fühlen,
sagt Cornelia jeweils,
ich würde alle umsorgen,
obwohl sie erwachsen sind.
Aber ich bin halt ein Rudeltier.
* Unterhaltung
auf Französisch und Arabisch *
Das Auto sieht in Ordnung aus.
- Ja.
Packe alles in die Mappe,
und wenn die Polizei kommt ...
Dann können sie alles anschauen.
Aber sie sind jeweils nett.
Ausser wenn du zu schnell fährst,
dann wollen sie ein wenig Geld.
Ein Morgen wie jeder andere,
der typische Familienalltag eben.
Kommt ihr essen?
Wir müssen nachher los.
Vor einem Jahr sind die Blums
von ihrer Abenteuerreise
nach Davos heimgekehrt.
Die Schüssel ist etwas gross,
fast ein Futtertrog.
Nicht auf den Tisch!
Der Alltag macht auch vor einer
Abenteurerfamilie nicht halt.
Die Mädchen gehen zur Schule:
Amira besucht die vierte Klasse,
die kleine Naira
ist im zweiten Kindergartenjahr.
Tschau, tschau.
- Tschüss.
Hat Amira alles dabei?
- Ja.
Hat sie alles eingepackt?
- Ich glaube schon.
Für den Schulranzen
ist neu Markus verantwortlich.
Die Blums haben die Rollen getauscht.
Markus ist Hausmann geworden,
sorgt sich um Haushalt und Kinder.
Tschüss, Schatz!
- Tschüss. Mach's gut!
Sabrina arbeitet
in einem Wellnesshotel im Spa.
Bis später.
- Bis später.
Tschau, tschau.
- Tschau, tschau.
Ich arbeite wieder 100 %
als Spatherapeutin.
Und ... äh ... ja.
Nach zehn Jahren
gehe ich sehr gerne arbeiten.
Wobei ich nebenbei
immer ein wenig gearbeitet habe,
und natürlich
war ich Hausfrau und Mutter.
Da habe ich viel gearbeitet -
wie viele andere Mütter auch.
Aber diesen Part abzugeben
und einen Rollentausch
mit meinem Mann zu vollziehen,
ist cool.
Und das, obwohl ihr Lohn tiefer sei
als der von Markus,
wenn er auf dem Bau arbeiten würde.
Wir wollten immer das machen,
was uns glücklich macht.
Und das kann man
nicht mit Geld aufwiegen.
Die Kinder erhalten so
auch eine andere Perspektive
auf die Geschlechterrollen.
Sie sehen: Die Frau geht 100 %
arbeiten, der Mann ist zu Hause.
Ich finde das toll,
für uns stimmt das.
In Schweden ist die Norrsken Lodge
komplett ausgebucht.
Damit es rund läuft, müssen Yasmine
und Max gemeinsam anpacken.
Das Ehepaar hat eine heftige
Beziehungskrise hinter sich.
Hallo!
Morgen!
Dabei wurde Yasmines Vertrauen in Max
heftig erschüttert.
Aber es scheint in der Natur
von Auswanderern zu liegen,
nicht schnell aufzugeben
und durchzuhalten.
Yasmine und Max
kämpften um ihr Glück.
Max bat mich,
es nochmals zu probieren.
Es müssen Gefühle da sein,
die sind auch da.
Er hat nie gesagt,
dass er mich nicht mehr liebe.
Das konnte er nie sagen -
und das glaube ich ihm auch.
Das Vertrauen
ist in gewisser Hinsicht da,
aber es ist immer noch so -
und das weiss er auch -,
dass es aufgebaut werden muss.
Und das ist seine Aufgabe.
Vertrauen ist etwas,
das es nicht zu kaufen gibt.
Es ist etwas,
das man einander nur schenken kann.
Doch Vergangenes ist vorbei.
Den Blick in die Zukunft gerichtet,
begann Yasmine trotz Hochsaison
eine Stuga zu renovieren.
Ich habe
viele meiner Ideen eingebracht.
Aber die Arbeiten haben v.a.
die Workawayers verrichtet.
Diese Stuga
war am meisten heruntergekommen.
Wir haben sie renoviert,
um zu sehen, was auf uns zukommt.
Wie gross
ist der finanzielle Aufwand?
Was muss gemacht werden,
wie kann man es machen?
Und auch: Wie aufwendig
sind die verschiedenen Schritte?
So konnten wir etwas daraus lernen.
Jede renovierte Stuga dekorieren sie
mit aufgezogenen Fotografien.
Wow!
- Gut so?
Fotografien von Nordlichtern,
aufgenommen von ihrer Lodge aus.
Viele Besucher kommen hierher,
um Nordlichter zu beobachten.
Schau mal!
Woah!
Oh!
- Ja, das wird noch gemacht.
Wir fahren zum Souk,
zum Bauernmarkt von Ida Ougourd,
der einmal pro Woche stattfindet.
So arbeite ich gern -
als Fremdenführerin.
Das mache ich gern.
Natürlich erwarte ich,
dass sie es so gut finden wie ich.
Es war eine etwas holprige Fahrt,
nicht?
Einen Parkplatz-Zuweiser
hätte ich hier nicht erwartet.
Wir müssen ihm
noch 2-3 Dirham geben.
Cornelia führt die Feriengäste
auf den Wochenmarkt von Ida Ougourd.
Sie weiss, welcher Bereich
die Gäste besonders beeindruckt.
Könnt ihr die Metzgerabteilung
vertragen? - Was?
Die Metzgerabteilung.
- Ich schon.
Ernst sowieso. Achtung!
Achtung, hier wird es etwas steinig!
Das ist das frischeste Fleisch,
das man haben kann.
Ja, schon. Ja.
Er hat einen Ziegenkopf aufgehängt,
damit man weiss,
dass er Ziegenfleisch verkauft.
Ja. Aber der Kopf
wird nicht gegessen, oder?
Ja ...
Vielleicht wird er noch ausgekocht.
Ja, ja.
- Aber ... Ja.
* Fröhliche Musik aus dem Radio *
* Pfeifen *
Frührentner Jean-Marie hat
ein buntes Erwerbsleben hinter sich.
Er war Briefträger,
hat ein Männerheim geleitet,
war im Strafvollzug
und im Asylwesen tätig.
Jetzt ist er
Hotelier und Küchenchef in einem.
(Radiomoderator)
Noch vor Ende Monat September
nochmals ein Rücktritt im Bundesrat.
CVP-Bundesrätin Doris Leuthard
tritt auf Ende 2018 zurück.
Doris Leuthard!
Am Morgen, gerade wenn ich abwasche
oder das Frühstück vorbereite,
höre ich gerne und oft ... DRS 1.
Ich höre die Nachrichten,
weil ich wissen will,
was in der Schweiz läuft.
Nur weil ich ausgewandert bin,
lässt mich die Schweiz nicht kalt.
Überhaupt nicht.
Es ist etwas Heimat in den Ohren.
* Pfeifen *
Alles wird heiss abgespült.
In Afrika hat es mehr Tiere
als bei uns, v.a. Ameisen.
Wenn das Geschirr nicht sauber ist,
ruft man die Ameisen auf den Plan.
Ob Käufer oder Verkäufer:
Der Markt von Ida Ougourd
wird von Männern dominiert.
Mögt ihr Melone?
- Ja.
Sie ist noch essbar.
Cornelia fühlt sich jedoch
als Frau und Ausländerin willkommen.
Zürich.
Bayern, Real Madrid ...
Am Markt ist es kein Thema.
Man ist ein Käufer und ...
Nein, das ist kein Thema.
So, Ernst.
Du bekommst auch noch ein Stück.
Diese Melone kostete 1.40 Fr.
Ist das für einen Coop-Preis gut?
Ja.
Hier wird man auch nicht betrogen.
Das sind ganz normale Preise.
* Verspielte Klänge *
Dass Markus nun den Haushalt besorgt,
war Sabrinas Idee.
Die Idee kam ihr,
als die Familie mit dem Wagen
durch das australische Outback rollte
und sie über ihre Zukunft nachdachte.
Ich finde es
für eine Partnerschaft das Grösste.
Also das Grösste ...
Nicht dass ich jetzt bügeln muss.
Aber es ist so, als ob
man sich nochmals neu verliebt.
Das gibt
einer Partnerschaft so viel.
Man hat neue Gesprächsthemen.
Man versteht sich gegenseitig.
Jetzt sind wir beide
mit anderen Themen konfrontiert.
Mega schön ...
* Handy *
Oh, Business.
Ich muss rangehen.
Hallo.
Hey, tschau.
Das fordert mich mehr,
als mit Kamelen durchs Outback
zu ziehen oder sonst was.
Business heisst für Hausmann Markus
ein Buch.
Die Geschichten der Blum'schen Reisen
durch Kanada und Australien
will er
zwischen zwei Buchdeckel packen.
Schon bald
geht das Buch in den Druck.
Es soll kein Heldenbericht werden.
Denn wir haben und hatten
auch unsere Krisen.
Das gehört zum Weg dazu.
Das berührt mich schon.
Man fühlt sich sofort zurückversetzt
in viele Situationen.
Es löst auch wieder ...
... neue Träume,
Visionen und Ziele aus.
Das macht sofort wieder süchtig.
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Das ist nicht ohne.
Bist du müde?
Ja.
- Echt?
Hänge es drinnen auf.
Ich mache das nicht für dich.
Komm!
Hattest du es gut?
- Super.
Darf ich ihn noch schnell ablegen?
Zum Mittagessen
kommt auch Sabrina nach Hause.
Mmh.
Ein Traum, ein Träumchen.
Konntest du staubsaugen?
- Ja.
Ich weiss, du kannst das,
aber hattest du auch Zeit? - Ja.
Im Schnelldurchlaufverfahren.
Diese Zucchetti ist lecker,
so mag ich sie nicht.
So nicht?
- Die ist zu pampig.
Ich weiss schon.
Schau dir das mal an!
Wie war's bei dir?
- Wir erhielten heute die Uniform.
Mit so einem Ausschnitt.
So werden wir
viel Trinkgeld verdienen.
Ich muss einen Knopf mitnehmen
und annähen.
Ist es gut?
Hat Papi gut gekocht?
Welche Fleischsorte ist das?
* Naira spricht unverständlich. *
Kommt! Wir gehen euch angurten.
Angurten.
Sie gehen jetzt in den Ferien-
Kindergarten, oder wie heisst das?
Ferienspielgruppe.
Ja, Ferienspielgruppe, genau.
Den Hintern anheben. So.
Die Kinder
wären sonst den ganzen Tag hier.
Ich kann nicht arbeiten und
gleichzeitig auf die Kinder achten.
Ich würde nur noch
die Kinder beaufsichtigen.
Das ist das Schicksal von Müttern,
die arbeiten.
Tschüss.
Um 16 Uhr holen wir sie ab,
dann sind sie bei uns
auf dem Spielplatz.
Das ist gut so.
Im kinderfreundlichen Schweden
kostet die Sommerspielgruppe
90 Fr. im Monat - für beide Buben.
Tschüss! Viel Spass!
- Dir auch.
Gehst du runter zu Janne?
Tipptopp.
Einmal im Jahr findet in Övertornea,
der neuen Heimatgemeinde
der Familie Hensler,
der grosse Sommermarkt statt.
Max nützt die Gelegenheit, um für
das Restaurant Werbung zu machen.
Das muss nur ein, zwei Tage halten.
Der Lunch rechnet sich nicht.
Wir bieten nur an speziellen Tagen
einen Lunch an:
am Markttag, an Weihnachten usw.
Ein Lunch darf nur 9 Fr. kosten,
mit Salat, Getränken und Kaffee.
Das rechnet sich nicht.
Das Restaurant ist das Sorgenkind
ihrer Hotel- und Campinganlage.
Zu viel Zeit und Kraft braucht es,
um den Betrieb vernünftig zu führen.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Hier ist die Einkaufstasche.
- Danke.
Oftmals stehen Yasmine und Max
selber in der Küche.
Denn einen guten Koch zu finden,
ist wahrlich Glücksache.
Jetzt hilft Jean-Pierre,
ein Koch aus Frankreich,
wenigstens
während der Sommerzeit aus.
C'est bon.
Seit Längerem versuchen die Eheleute,
das Restaurant zu verpachten.
Wir wollen Zeit mit den Kindern,
als Familie verbringen.
Wir fanden
keine seriösen Interessenten,
die das Restaurant
übernehmen würden.
In Schweden sowieso nicht.
Die Schweden
möchten nicht so viel arbeiten.
Am liebsten hätte ich
einen jungen, knackigen Schweizer
mit drei, vier Jahren Erfahrung in
etwa zwei verschiedenen Restaurants,
der etwas aufbauen möchte.
Das wäre toll.
Einer, der hart arbeitet und Ver-
antwortung übernimmt, das wäre toll.
Ups.
Heute erwarten Cornelia
und Jean-Marie neue Gäste aus Bern.
Ich schliesse noch die Tür
wegen des Huhns. - Ja.
Gäste in Empfang zu nehmen
und die Zimmer vorzubereiten,
das ist Cornelias Aufgabenbereich.
Und sie war es auch,
die die Renovationsarbeiten
der Gästehäuser vorangetrieben hat.
V.a. haben wir
das Badezimmer neu gemacht.
Nur hat es hier gar kein Badezimmer.
Das ist immer
die grosse Überraschung.
Ta-da, das Badezimmer!
Das hier ist nigelnagelneu.
Dank Jean-Maries Rente
und den tiefen Lebenshaltungskosten
kommen die Aargauer
gut über die Runden.
Es reicht,
wenn wir die Unkosten decken können
und zusätzlich noch etwas
für unseren Lebensunterhalt
übrig bleibt.
Aber wir müssen nicht
viel Geld verdienen.
So können wir
eine familiäre Atmosphäre schaffen.
Wir haben Zeit für die Gäste.
Ja.
Das macht letztlich
auch das Spezielle bei uns aus.
Hoffentlich schaut kein
professionelles Zimmermädchen zu.
Wenn es ruhig ist in der Villa
Tabouka, macht Jean-Marie Lärm.
Dann widmet er sich seiner
Leidenschaft, dem Pfeifenbau.
Seine ganze Werkstatt
hat er aus der Schweiz mitgenommen.
Er wagt ein Experiment:
eine Pfeife aus lokalem Arganholz.
Ich gebe ihr jetzt
noch etwas mehr Form.
Später schaue ich,
wie gut man mit ihr rauchen kann.
Aha.
Ist Cornelia da, oder was?
Ist Cornelia da, oder nicht?
Ist sie nicht da?
Wir müssen rasch unterbrechen.
Grüezi miteinander.
Ich hörte euch gar nicht kommen.
Jean-Marie.
- Heidi.
Freut mich.
- Toni.
Hätte nicht Cornelia die Gäste
in Empfang nehmen sollen?
Jean-Marie. Vera.
- Andrin.
Andrin?
- Ja.
Ein Bündner Name?
Freut mich.
Gut.
Cornelia ist anscheinend nicht da.
So.
Ihr habt Wasser.
Wo hat sie es hingestellt?
Wasser, Wasser ... dort!
Dort steht Wasser -
und bei euch, so glaube ich, auch.
Was gibt es noch zu sagen?
Cornelia wird noch runterkommen
und es euch genauer erklären.
Ich bin nicht richtig gekleidet.
Aber ... fühlt euch wie zu Hause.
Gut. Okay.
- Bis später.
Bis später.
Ich habe mich geärgert
und ärgere mich jetzt noch.
Ich habe dich vermisst.
Vorne waren genug Leute.
- Wie?
Aha. Okay.
Es war peinlich, die Gäste in meinen
Werkstattkleidern zu empfangen.
Ich musste den Gästen die Unterkunft
in verstaubten Kleidern zeigen.
Das war ein wenig peinlich.
Schau mal! So verschwitzt und alles
kann man doch nicht ...
Zudem ist es nicht meine Aufgabe.
Ich habe es falsch verstanden.
Ich dachte,
Cornelia werde die Gäste empfangen.
Ich habe es missverstanden
und ärgere mich über mich selber.
In Bern findet jedes Jahr
das Fernwehfestival statt.
Hoi. Bist du gerade gekommen?
- Ich habe Tic Tacs erhalten.
Heute wollen die Blums
ihr Abenteuerbuch vorstellen.
Es ist nicht so gross, nicht?
Es ist riesig!
Das macht mich nervöser
als jedes Kamel.
Ich bin einfach kein Techniker.
Am Morgen war mir übel.
Ich dachte, ich müsse erbrechen.
Ich erzähle gerne -
aber eher im kleinen Kreis.
Ich kann schon mit vielen Emotionen
von unseren Reisen erzählen.
Aber bei so vielen Zuhörern
werde ich nervös.
Es ist nicht das erste Mal,
dass die Blums vor grossem Publikum
von ihren Reisen erzählen.
Das kommt schon gut. Easy, locker.
Überwindung braucht es trotzdem.
Über 200 Besucher wollen wissen,
wie es ist,
sich mit der ganzen Familie
auf eine Abenteuerreise zu wagen.
Willkommen auf dem Podium.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Sabrinas Nervosität legt sich,
sobald sie zu erzählen beginnt.
Wir waren immer
für unsere Kinder da,
durften viel Zeit
mit ihnen verbringen.
Und hinten
die langsamen vier Kamele.
Man ist im Schritttempo unterwegs.
Man kann sehr gut
neben ihnen herlaufen.
Merci vielmals. Danke.
- Merci.
Das habt ihr aber schön gemacht.
Ja, ihr dürft auch.
Wenn sie eine Unterschrift wollen.
Hey, cool!
Du bist der Erste, so geil!
Ihr seid eine megacoole Family.
Im Blum'schen Familienunternehmen
werden auch die Töchter Amira
und Naira eingespannt.
Mit zehn Jahren signiert Amira
bereits ihr erstes Buch.
Das hier bist du.
Ah, sehr gut. Nicht du?
- Ah, schön.
Alles rein.
Du musst ihr noch Geld geben.
Das und das musst du ihr geben.
Es würde sich wohl nur rechnen,
wenn wir 10'000 Stück verkaufen
und zehn Auflagen machen würden.
Aber wir arbeiten
in einem kleinen Rahmen.
Das Buch soll dem Leser zeigen,
dass jeder
so etwas unternehmen kann.
Man muss diesen Schritt wagen
und die Komfortzone verlassen.
Machst du das?
- Danke vielmals.
25 Fr.
- Hier sind 25 Fr.
Dann gebe ich euch gleich 70 Fr.
Warte schnell!
Es ist wie so oft bei uns:
Wir machen einfach mal und schauen.
Aber wir glauben natürlich
auch daran, dass es funktioniert.
Das ist super. Danke vielmals.
Nein, es sind nur 21 Fr.
Schon gut.
Sonst später bei einem Kaffee.
In Nordschweden ist Hitze angesagt:
34 °C sollen es heute werden.
Und heute soll auch
das Drachenbootrennen stattfinden.
Rokhi nennen sich Ramus und Anton,
die Partyband aus Övertornea.
Es wird
ein richtig kleiner Grossanlass.
Das Barteam ist bereit für die Gäste.
Bei den Schweden weiss man nie,
wie viele kommen.
Ich denke, auch die Camper
werden noch dazustossen,
was noch schön wäre - mal schauen.
Die Terrasse zur Bar und der Steg
sind Max' grosser Stolz.
Hunderte Arbeitsstunden
hat er im letzten Jahr
in den Neubau investiert.
Es sei auch
der längste Steg der Region.
Doch hat er
während des Hochwassers arg gelitten.
Am Tag des Rennens will Max diesen
noch schnell auseinandernehmen.
Er steht nicht mehr am gleichen Ort,
der Steg hat sich verschoben.
Im Frühling machte uns die Natur
einen Strich durch die Rechnung.
Letztes Jahr
war die Flut nicht so stark,
dieses Jahr war sie so stark
wie seit 50 Jahren nicht mehr.
Durch diese Kraft
treibt das Holz natürlich auf.
Wir haben es mit Steinen beschwert,
um es zu retten
oder in Position zu halten.
Aber das ganze Betonfundament
wurde angehoben.
Der Steg war komplett unter Wasser.
Hier rechts
war alles komplett unter Wasser.
Dadurch trieb auch Eis hinein.
Wir hatten auch Angst,
dass das Wasser in die Häuser läuft.
Das wäre katastrophal gewesen.
Nun wollen sie den Steg
von den Betonsockeln lösen
und vorübergehend
direkt auf der Wiese deponieren.
Pass auf, wenn du drunter bist!
Hier hängt es fest.
Irgendwo hier.
Dafür will er den Steg
in 4 m lange Einzelteile zerlegen.
Die Schraubenverbindung
geht hier durch.
Zu aufwendig - Max muss abbrechen.
Es klappt nicht. Wir haben zu viele
Einzelteile, die wir anheben wollen.
Wir brauchen diese Zeit
für das Drachenbootfestival.
Wir erledigen das nächste Woche.
Dafür: piekfein.
In Essaouira ist Jean-Marie
unterwegs zur Wäscherei.
Salam aleikum.
Cornelia hat ihn beauftragt,
Gästewäsche abzuholen.
* Gemächliche Klänge *
Es läuft nichts,
er findet das Zeug nicht.
Es ist immer das Gleiche.
Man muss schauen, dass man
seine Wäsche wieder bekommt,
wegen der Dimensionen und alles ...
Es ist wahrscheinlich schwierig.
Ce n'est pas fini?
- Pardon, ce soir.
Ce soir?
- Oui?
A quelle heure?
- Sept heures.
Sept heures?
- Oui.
Okay.
* Verabschiedung auf Arabisch *
Bonne journee.
Na gut, abends um 19 Uhr.
Manchmal muss man
etwas fatalistisch sein.
Ich kann es nicht ändern, also
rege ich mich gar nicht gross auf.
Nun muss Cornelia
um 19 Uhr nochmals vorbeigehen.
Cornelia ist wieder
als Fremdenführerin unterwegs.
Die neueste Attraktion:
Esel-Teenager Maisha.
Komm, Mädchen.
Komm, Mädchen. Gehen wir runter?
Gehen wir runter? Ja.
Wir haben eine Eseldame gekauft,
nicht wahr?
Und dann wurde sie
plötzlich runder und runder.
Und im Februar ...
... kam sie zur Welt.
Nicht beissen! Also, gehen wir?
Die Kleine läuft einfach Mami nach.
Warte!
Gut.
Bei der Kleinen
muss man manchmal aufpassen,
dass sie aus lauter Übermut
nicht ausschlägt.
Toni, auch du darfst aufsitzen.
Nein, der bricht nicht zusammen.
Der Marokkaner sagt:
"400 kg, kein Problem."
Zweimal pro Woche
holt Cornelia ihre Tiere zur Villa.
Es ist kaum ein Jahr her,
dass Cornelia zum ersten Mal
auf einem Esel geritten ist.
Heute ist sie
eine gestandene Eselführerin.
Komm, laufen wir ein wenig.
Haben wir die Kleine vergessen?
Bist du noch oben?
- Ja, ja.
Komm!
Warte schnell!
- Willst du runter? Geht's?
Gut.
Es klappt gut, auf ihr zu reiten.
Kein Problem.
Und tschüss!
Die Kleine
hat schon grossen Appetit.
Sie hat grossen Appetit.
Sie ist auch gewachsen.
- Ja.
Diese Esel
kennen dich natürlich bestens.
Anfangs hatte ich
jeweils eine Karotte dabei.
Das ist nicht mehr nötig.
Rauf!
Geht's so?
So tut es am Hintern weniger weh.
- Ja.
Halte dich hier fest! Na also.
Während Sabrinas Zimmerstunde
hat das Ehepaar Zeit für Zweisamkeit.
Mami muss in die Pedale treten,
du musst dich selber festhalten.
Ups, falscher Gang.
- Fahren wir den Kiesweg runter?
Dann schüttelt es dich
aber ziemlich durch.
Doch zuerst bringen sie Naira
in den Kindergarten.
Vielleicht sind wahre Abenteurer
Menschen,
die jeden Tag ein Quäntchen
Erlebnis suchen und finden.
Absteigen.
Gut.
Jetzt gehen wir da über die Strasse.
Gut schauen!
Wollen wir gleich hier runter?
- Ja, hier.
Tschüss! Bis ...
- Tschüss!
Okay.
Markus' und Sabrinas
heutiges kleines "Auf und davon":
eine Schussfahrt
vom Jakobshorn ins Tal.
Woah!
* Dynamische Musik *
Das ist cool.
Besser als den Haushalt zu führen?
- Ja, definitiv.
Super! Das ist cool.
Ich geniesse es,
wenn ich abends nach Hause komme,
die Kinder im Bett sind
und die Küche aufgeräumt ist -
meistens aufgeräumt ist.
Ich geniesse das richtig.
Es war schön, dass ich
mit den Kindern zu Hause sein
und viel Zeit
mit ihnen verbringen durfte.
Ich war eigentlich immer für sie da.
Und jetzt wieder
ins Berufsleben einzusteigen
und solche Momente miteinander
erleben zu dürfen, ist toll.
Das sind super Momente,
die man auch ausnützen muss.
Denn solche Momente
ergeben sich nicht immer.
Wenn man etwas unternehmen kann,
ist das schon cool.
Ich glaube, das weiss jeder ...
Alle Eltern wissen,
dass man manchmal verzichten muss.
Und wenn man solche Momente
plötzlich wieder hat, umso besser.
Man muss sich diese Stunden
schon herausnehmen.
Man darf nicht nur
ständig darüber reden,
sondern muss es auch umsetzen.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Noch sind es kleine,
alltägliche Abenteuer.
Huch! Da könnte man stürzen.
Doch das nächste grosse
kommt bestimmt.
Hoi.
- Willkommen.
In der Villa Tabouka
nehmen Cornelia und Jean-Marie
das Ehepaar Spitteler aus Solothurn
gemeinsam in Empfang.
Socken sind derzeit
nicht mehr nötig.
Nein, brauchen wir nicht.
Viel besser, nicht?
Kaffee und Teebeutel.
Schau dir das mal an!
Auf Holz zum Einfeuern
habe ich verzichtet.
Die Solothurner waren schon einmal
zu Besuch bei den Aargauern.
Wir haben Kaffee getrunken
und sie haben erzählt,
wie sie das gemacht haben.
Das hat uns überzeugt,
denn man spürt hier eine Wärme.
Darauf sprechen wir auch an.
Man fühlt sich hier wohl.
Diese Dame kennt ihr noch nicht.
Ich habe sie soeben bewundert.
Es sieht wunderbar aus.
Komm runter!
Manchmal, wenn in der Gästevilla
alle versorgt sind,
machen die beiden Auswanderer einen
Ausflug an die Küste nach Essaouira.
* Entspannte, orientalische Klänge *
"Moroccan Rock Music tonight" -
so schön.
Hier kann man runterschauen.
- Wow!
Hier sind die Kanonen.
Hu-hu!
Wunderschön.
Un cocktail de fruits.
Et puis la pastilla
aux fruits de mer.
Zwischendurch mal abhauen
und Zeit für uns beide haben.
Das tut nicht nur gut,
es ist auch gut.
Ich glaube, das ist wichtig.
- Ja, das muss auch sein.
Denn mit einem Betrieb,
einer Sieben-Tage-Woche und Gästen
müssen wir uns
zwischendurch wieder kennenlernen.
Alors.
- Shukran habibi. Merci.
Was wir jetzt aufgezogen haben ...
... das ist meiner Meinung nach
eine gelungene Sache.
Wir würden auch etwas ausstrahlen,
diesem Ort
eine persönliche Note geben.
Deshalb sind die Gäste
auch wieder gekommen.
Es ist schön, wenn man von Gästen
ein solches Feedback erhält.
Schlussendlich kann ein Mensch
überall
auf diesem blauen Planeten leben,
solange er Sauerstoff erhält,
Wasser hat
und seine Bedürfnisse
befriedigt werden.
Man kann überall Wurzeln schlagen.
Ja, wenn man sich wohlfühlt.
Und das ist bei uns der Fall.
Wir sind Schweizer und Schweizerin
und bleiben auch
Schweizer und Schweizerin.
Das wird sich nicht mehr ändern.
Oh!
Madame,
la pastilla aux fruits de mer.
Wash-shifa!
- Wash-shifa!
(Beide) Guten Appetit!
Cornelia und Jean-Marie
waren offen für das, was kam.
Sie nahmen
die marokkanische Realität an
und wurden vielleicht
gerade deswegen beschenkt
mit Zufriedenheit
in ihrem neuen Lebensabschnitt.
Auch wenn nur eine kleine Regatta
stattfindet ...
Hej, hej.
... das Drachenbootrennen
zieht viele Besucher an.
Zwei Drachenboote
starten in den Wettkampf -
am Ruder alles Bewohner
von Övertornea.
Die Henslers sind mit ihrer Lodge
zur lokalen Attraktion geworden.
Jetzt darfst du.
- Aber weit weg halten!
Janne ist für den korrekten Start
zuständig.
Drücken!
* Tröten *
Hopp Rot! Hopp Rot! Hopp Rot!
Hopp Gelb! Hopp Gelb! Hopp Gelb!
* Anfeuerungsrufe *
Gelb ist schnell und holt auf.
* Tröten *
Die Familie
ist angekommen in Schweden.
Mit der Schweiz aber werden
zumindest die Eltern
verbunden bleiben.
Bist du mehr Schwede oder Schweizer?
Schwede.
- Schwede? Okay.
Schwede. - Schwede! Okay.
* Lachen *
Letztes Jahr war ich
mehr Schwede als jetzt.
Ich besann mich wieder
auf meine heimischen Wurzeln.
Ich finde es auch toll, hier oben
eine Schweizer Fahne zu sehen.
Und auch unseren schwedischen Gästen
gefällt diese Mischung.
Hä?
Janne, es gibt Hotdogs.
* Fröhliche Country-Musik *
Willst du dich zu Dan setzen?
- Ja.
Dann setz dich zu ihm.
Zuerst High five und Hallo sagen.
High five.
- Sprich Schwedisch mit ihm!
Ich stand vorhin da,
schaute mich um und dachte: "Wow!"
Ich war mir unsicher,
ob es wahr oder ein Traum ist.
Man sieht die Leute, hört den Sound,
sieht die Kinder und denkt:
"Wow, das gehört alles uns."
Das habe ich noch oft,
dass ich denke:
"Oh Gott, wow, unglaublich!"
* Fröhliche Country-Musik *
Geglücktes Auswandern ist,
wenn man wie Max und Yasmine
stolz auf das neue Leben blicken
und feststellen kann:
Es hat sich gelohnt.
* Applaus *
Komm, gemeinsam klatschen.
Jedes Jahr gibt es Schweizerinnen und
Schweizer, die ihren Träumen folgen.
Einige von ihnen
werden wir dabei begleiten.
Stefano Navarretta und Stefano Lotti
wittern in Mexiko ihre grosse Chance.
Wir sind hierhergekommen,
um Geld zu verdienen.
Im Ferienparadies in der Karibik
steigen sie
ins Immobiliengeschäft ein.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
So kann man das Bett nicht klauen,
das ist auch gut.
Hilfe erhalten sie
von Stefanos Onkel.
Er lebt schon lange in Mexiko.
Mein Onkel behandelt mich
schon fast wie einen Sohn.
Denn die neue Heimat
ist voller Gegensätze und Extreme.
Auf den ersten zehn Seiten waren
tote Leute, dann kam der Sport.
Die ersten 4 Std. in Schweden
sind super.
Ich hoffe,
das geht 40 Jahre so weiter.
Markus Buob und seine Frau Sylvia
suchen in Schweden die Ruhe.
In der Heimat von Pippi Langstrumpf
kaufen sie einen Hof am See.
Es ist immer noch
ein wenig befremdend,
wenn man realisiert,
dass das Haus uns gehört.
Sie wollen Ferienwohnungen vermieten.
Doch bis sich die Gäste hier
wohlfühlen, gibt es noch viel zu tun.
Markus ist weitgehend
auf sich allein gestellt.
Ich würde gerne mit anpacken.
Sylvia ist schwanger.
Sie erwartet ihr erstes Kind.
Soeben
ist meine Fruchtblase geplatzt.
Ohne Vorwarnung.
Familie Tokay geht auf und davon
Richtung Südafrika.
Wir wollen unser Leben umgestalten.
Es ist ein Familienprojekt.
Im Gepäck ein Container
voller Hausrat aus der Schweiz.
Das ist abenteuerlich.
Ein Davoser Schlitten,
den wir hier nie brauchen werden.
Sie träumen von einer Lodge.
Aber das passende Objekt finden,
das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Das ist aber billig gemacht.
- Ja.
Nichts Spezielles.
Und auch den Kindern fällt
der Start ins neue Leben schwer.
Mir ist alles zu viel.
- Ja, Schritt für Schritt.
Wir gehen nicht zurück, nur
weil nicht alles nach Plan läuft.
Die neue Staffel von "Auf und davon",
ab 4. Januar um 21 Uhr auf SRF 1.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2018